[Music]
let's go to sylvia in the city of angels
los angeles what's up sylvia
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm doing well thank you yeah you just
hit me with that conflict deferred
conflict amplified uh-oh
oh oh i feel like
that's how we're gonna end my call too
oh great all right so what's up
so
my direct question is
should i reach out to my son's father
who i haven't talked to since my son was
basically born
tell me more
so
i'm really nervous
okay
so
we dated for about six months
um
and in those six months
the last time i saw him we were intimate
and
we used the plan b
and
after that like we that was the last
time i saw him we were on the we kept
talking but i realized like
maybe i don't want to be with him and i
didn't know i was pregnant and then i
was okay so y'all y'all hooked up you
all slept together you went the next day
took the plan b pill and then moved on
with your day and then a couple of days
a couple weeks later y'all broke up and
you moved on with your life yeah and
then six weeks later i found out i was
pregnant okay
so when i told him about it we were
already broken up
and
he told me to
terminate the pregnancy okay and i said
i wasn't gonna do that and
and
he just kept pressuring me and
pressuring me to have
an abortion and i just kept saying no
so
for the first six months of my pregnancy
um i
i tried to not answer his message i
didn't see him at all through my whole
pregnancy well during the six first six
months we almost didn't talk but when i
was six months he came back and was
supposedly okay let's let's try to work
things out but we never actually saw
each other
and then like a month later
you know when i was seven months
pregnant he's like you know what never
mind i'm not ready to be a father and i
don't understand why you decided to keep
this child you're putting me in a bad
situation you've ruined my life
you just got pregnant for a paycheck
and he just
i mean i don't want to cry but he just
like i just felt really humiliated yeah
because of what he did
yes that was uh
un it's disgusting what he said to you
it's cowardly and it's disgusting and
it's childish
i'm sorry that somebody did that to you
yes so
we i kept communication open for my son
because i felt like
you know maybe eventually he'll change
his mind and this is his first child
maybe he'll
want to come around
so
i said
if you don't talk to me respectfully i'm
not gonna respond good but if you want
to know how the pregnancy is going how
the baby is going
will respond to those questions so we
did continue communication in that way
and when i went into labor we were we
were talking and hold on you keep
talking about communication and
y'all are talking
are you just talking about you're
texting each other
yes because i was like listen listen
listen to him that is not communication
you are passing data back and forth to
each other
you have not had a real relationship
with him no that's
if you're afraid that's wise if you're
afraid wise good move on your part
but it really sounds like
you had a picture in your head
that you weren't going to be one of
those people who had us a kid by
themself like that's not going to happen
to me and it happened to you
exactly you've been propping up this
picture
for a long time now
and
it the guy left
he told you he wanted you to kill the
baby and move on with your life
yes
so he's told you what he wants
what's
absolutely melting you from the inside
out is the energy you're spending trying
to prop up a picture of something that's
gone
do you see what i'm saying
yeah in a strange way the conflict
deferred statement is you you're at
conflict with you
this guy's told you he left you
he left his beautiful son
he left
god's making me so just
unbelievable
i'm heartbroken for you like in a deep
way because i don't like to be out of
town more than a day away from my kids i
can't wrap my head around somebody who
would want to walk away from their kids
i can't i don't have the psychology for
it i can't wrap my head around it's not
something i can understand
i know i'm
in my heart my son is three years old
and i've only left them with us with my
sister to watch three times in here in
his whole life well that's gonna make
you crazy sylvia
you need to go do fun things too you
need to have friends you need to be out
having fun and he can stay with a
babysitter or a family member you know
what i mean
yeah so why why is this just now coming
back up why are you just now wondering
should i reach out
because my son is talking now
and he's very smart and he notices like
cartoons have like songs have mom and
dad
you know coco melon is
daddy and mommy and
you know baby shark is mama shark papa
shark everything like bluey has this
papa bluey and hey blue he's
dad is screwing it up for everybody that
guy's like dad of the century
i watched that show and i'm like man
level up delony like yes so blue is not
really fair that that's incredible
yeah so i know i just kind of feel like
it's gonna come it is it is mine it is
and here's the response
daddy wasn't well and so he uh chose to
go
daddy loved you and um but daddy was not
well that he was sick
and he chose to go away
and here's the unfortunate thing
you know this as well as i do
that little boy's gonna wonder what he
did wrong
to send that away
he's gonna wonder that for the rest of
his life
and here's what's gonna happen you're
gonna do a really great job raising this
little boy
he won the lottery with you as a mama
and you're going to do a great job
and then at some point dad's going to
swoop back in
and everything in your life is
gonna be gritting your teeth and say
stay away from that man he's a bad man
and at some point you're gonna have to
choose peace and you're gonna have to
choose forgiveness because that's the
father of your son and if you talk bad
about him or if he comes to believe that
dad is evil and wrong that little boy
knows that half of me is him
so your son's going to walk around
feeling like half of him is broken and
def and defective
i'm not planning on on that um i never
talk bad about him no i know i know i am
i know i know i'm just saying like it
like
it's gonna be a tough road to hoe that's
what happens when dads walk out on their
families
yeah i mean honestly i wish it will
happen sooner rather than later for my
son's sake
and like you're saying i will always try
to keep peace but at the same time i'm
afraid that when he does come every
little
situation would be like well i told you
not to have him
or you know
you're making yourself crazy trying to
prop up a picture that's not gonna
happen
the guy's gone when's the last time you
had a face-to-face conversation with him
when we conceived a baby
four and a half years ago
when's the last time you had a text
message conversation with him
when my son was five days old so it's
been three years
yeah do you even know where he is
no
last time we spoke he said he had bought
a house in another state but i don't
know if he's still there
um
i'll give you
my thoughts
i think you should take him to court for
child support
and
i think he should be
um
take care of if he wants to walk away
and
and neglect his family in that way
whatever
um but he's got a financial
responsibility to this kid
that's what i think
um and it and
or you can just wipe your hands of it
and be done and as he gets older
he's gonna have to reckon with it wasn't
me there was something wrong with my dad
that made him do a very unnatural act
which was to leave
a pregnant mom
and then he's gonna have to make peace
with that inside of him
and that's going to be his healing
adventure that he goes on probably for a
long long time
yeah a lot of
well my my family totally does not want
me to put him on child support but i
have a
couple friends
because truthfully i don't need him
financially i mean extra
money will always help i can put it in
my son's savings account or something
but truthfully i don't need his money
okay um and i just feel like i don't
know i don't know how much he would give
me like 300 500 whatever amount it is
it's not worth for me him telling me
see
i told you you just did this for a
paycheck and you just did this
you know he threw a grenade at you
when he was a scared kid
he threw a grenade at you that is still
burning through your heart
he said some stupid stuff
that doesn't neglect the fact
that he needs to take financial
responsibility for his son
right
and you're you you are you are
suffering
because you don't want to fulfill an
insult that he made to you
yeah
banana sylvia
he doesn't get a vote man
he doesn't get a vote
in how you feel he cashed that out
he doesn't get a vote how you feel he
doesn't get a vote how he raises how
this kid gets raised he doesn't get a
vote he left he walked away do you still
have all those text messages
yes yeah
yeah i would save all those i'd print
them off somehow
yeah i do they're gonna look great being
read in court
telling me that i ruined his life
that
that he told me um
he told me that every time he because i
wanted him to be more
sylvia why are you giving him voice into
your head this many years later
maybe because i don't know at this point
i grew up without my dad i know i want
to do everything possible for my son to
have a father he left you he left
he left
yeah
and that's because something was
something was wrong with him not you
and you still carry it around that your
dad left because of something you did
that's not true
your dad left because of him not you
quit carrying that around sylvia
actually
i i was in therapy and my therapist said
you know because i told her
when do you think i'll have a
breakthrough you know and she said when
you don't
hold regret or
not regret when you don't hold up like
uh grudge or hate towards your dad
and and when she said that i'm like
never like that's never gonna happen but
now i realize now i i i do feel that way
i'm like it wasn't me
he had his own priorities and obviously
i wasn't working no no no no no no no no
okay here's what you got to do
you've got uh here's your homework
assignment you ready
i want you to pick up
um i want you to go to home depot
and it'll cost you like five bucks
okay
that's like one
one
twentieth or one one hundredth of a of a
price of a psychiatrist visit okay
i want you to pick up um go to the back
of the garden section and pick up a
landscaping brick
and i want you to put a piece of duct
tape over that brick and i want you to
write
dad left
and i'm mad
and i want you to carry that brick
around for an hour around your house you
cannot set it down you can't put it on
your lap you have to hold it
okay
and i want you just to keep carrying it
when you go to the grocery store when
you go in the backyard and you take the
trash out whatever it is you're doing
you play with your son you can make
mommy why are you carrying that
prediction back because some [ __ ] on a
podcast told me to do it
and i want you to carry it around and
your shoulders are going to ache and
your hands are going to get tired
and at some point i want you to take
that brick out in your backyard and
throw it as far as you can and never
pick it up again
that is forgiveness
forgiveness doesn't let your dead off
the hook forgiveness says i'm not
carrying your poison anymore
because right now sylvia you are
drinking poison every day of your life
hoping your dad feels it and he doesn't
yeah and you're like my son's death yes
and you're picking up a cup of poison
from your son's dad and you drink it
every morning hoping that he feels it
and he doesn't
the only person who's getting poisoned
is you
stop
you're worth so much more than this
right
yeah yes
let it let set it down
set it down you are gonna have to be
highly intentional about putting other
men in your son's life he's gonna need
men not saying like have a rotation of
of people you're dating through the
house he's gonna need a grandparent or
uncles or
men that you trust from a local church
or from a local school that will lean
into his life and so you're gonna be
proactive
hey you're a man in my life that i trust
would you be willing to take my son for
an hour a week and just go play
just let him have some interaction time
go kick a soccer ball go throw a ball go
rough house go do something
take him to a park
and there are men who will do that i've
done that for people
there are men who will step up and do
that because there's some extraordinary
men out there
but at this point it's been four and a
half years you're hanging on to a ghost
you're hanging on to a wisp to an ether
that doesn't exist the man left
he said i want you to kill this baby
because you've ruined my life i'm gone
and he left he's gone
and you say you don't you don't need his
financial support and it's not even
worth the drama oh that's your life i'll
support you on that
stop drinking poison sylvia stop
you're worth a good night's sleep
you're worth laughter you're worth
loving again
all these things you didn't screw up you
didn't do anything wrong
you're a good mom
carry that brick around for a while and
then i want you to feel what it feels
like to set it down
and i'll say it one more time
your dad left because there was
something wrong with him
not you
the father of your son left because he
was struggling with whatever he's
struggling with
not because of you
stop carrying that set it down